combining science fiction action with
crew Schumer a vast mythology
I'm just the tiniest bit of heart Rick
and Morty was an instant hit when it
debuted on Adult Swim in late 2013 the
creation of animator and voice actor
Justin roiland and community creator Dan
Harmon
the animated series follows The
Adventures of a somewhat reprehensible
usually drunk scientists and his kind of
dumb grandson as they traveled through
space-time and ultimate dimensions
messing up history the universe and
their own lives in the process
here's a look at the untold truth of
Rick and Morty doc and Marty the whole
thing started when Ryland made an
animated short called the real animated
adventures of doc and Marty a very
thinly veiled sexually explicit parody
of Back to the Future
if that sounds insane that's because it
is right Rowlands cartoons were screened
as part of a weekly film showcase in Los
Angeles run by Harmon when Harmon got
temporarily fired from community
he approached royland about adapting doc
and Marty into a recurring series that
toned down some of the more explicit
sexual content doc became Rick Marty
became more teeth but person became
whatever is it has been a challenging
meeting season for birdperson and it's
time to get your beak wet tonight playah
go have some fun out there birds bird
person gas giant I have a new
catchphrase I need your help 40 I mean
we got we gotta get the hell out of here
and go take care of business that's
important come on Morty Rick's endless
birthing is definitely gross and it's
definitely real Weyland who voices both
Rick and Morty says that during
voiceover recording till read-through
Rick's lines once and mark down where he
wants to insert the first later the
album's a bunch of millet xt4 and water
roland goes back and rerecord his
dialogue this time with belches in their
proper place he says the whole process
is disgusting you can't just add a site
by word you a car word
open means something that's not the only
all-natural part of the process the
optical feel too much of the dialogue is
because Wayland engages in a process of
improvisation during recording after
running Rick's lines Roland does a read
through some water and then does the
take of the scenes of both characters
letting himself bridge the end result is
the collage of descriptive and
improvised lines that are animated
around resulting in some pretty
amazingly weird and occasionally drunk
stuff Instagram innovation hundreds of
shows debuted on the internet but Rick
and Morty is the first to ever premiere
an entire episode on Instagram due to
instagrams video limitation of 15
seconds that meant the 2014 episode
Rick's the minutes had to be cut up into
a hundred and nine separate videos
building on its unique success the show
team also did something else nobody had
done on Instagram before you as a game
platform rigged Stuber launched in the
summer of 2015
players must follow tags and other clues
to bounce through more than 80 Instagram
accounts set up and dedicated
exclusively to the game more than one
hundred and twenty-nine thousand people
took part in Rick's uh birth which
involved eleven explorable planets and
more than a thousand individual images
and tied into the season to equip hangar
and even offered players the opportunity
to contribute to season three by naming
a weird alien blog the couch gag my god
look at the baby one oh my god Morty
in 2016 the Rick and Morty team put
together one of the most memorable
Simpsons - gags in recent history Justin
roiland at heard that The Simpsons
creator Matt Groening was a fan of his
show sorry
asked graining to provide the commentary
track on the DVD release of the first
season of Rick and Morty graining agreed
and brought along long conferences
writer and producer al
Jing who asked Ruolin to do the
time-travel attachment and surprisingly
allowing him to brutally murdered
Springfield's first family so only that
while the couch gag also doubled as a
Futurama crossover and given the fact
that Rick and Morty takes place in a
vast multiverse it's not surprising that
this isn't the shows only crosser
gravity falls though they come from very
different places and have very different
audiences the traction between gravity
falls and Rick and Morty are too
plentiful to ignore gravity falls
creator Alex Hirsch and done voice work
on Rick and Morty and Weyland has
returned the favor on hirtius show
that's amazing aah are you from the
future or something oh no oh don't do
that
memory wipe this is a baby wipe not too
surprising since they used to share an
office at the Disney Channel but it goes
deeper for example gravity falls evil
pyramid shapes dream demon bill cipher
briefly appeared in Rick and Morty as
Hirsch told Entertainment Weekly it's a
dream come true
saying the summary lil the universe has
blessed us with our mad wishes and it
occurred to us let's start doing things
nobody else does that maybe you're not
supposed to do we started putting little
Easter eggs in our shows that sort of
connected the to a motivation for that
is primarily to freak people out and
blow their mind one of the most
mind-blowing Easter eggs occurs when
spoiler alert items sucked into a portal
in gravity falls pop out to a portal in
Rick and Morty
Rick's a mystery and vast and
complicated as the Rick and Morty mythos
has become well ended Harmon never want
to give too much information about the
history of Rick Harmon told The AV Club
were careful about delving into Rick's
backstory because what we do we don't
want there to be any shocking surprises
like Yoda and Tommy waz Oh
Rick's real story may never be revealed
and that's just one of the shows
mystery the plot thickens the shortest
creative staff decided they wanted to
have a secret about the show's world but
only they would not they would never
explicitly reveal their secret during
the run of Rick and Morty but they did
want to place closed drew out which is
fans are nearly obsessive
someone managed to figure out the secret
posted it on reddit royland confirmed
that someone figured it out but didn't
identify the secret based on the posts
related to these theories and violent
reaction fans have narrowed down the
most likely possibilities could Rick be
an older version of 40 or is it one of
the many versions of is Rick where that
is a fictional character are you next
like everybody
or maybe Rick's flask isn't filled with
boots but instead the powerful magazine
you got to put these deep inside your
butt
come on Morty please more you have to do
it more oh man you know the ones that
temporarily make you smart then kind of
crippled for a while reality you're a
star I come but the most important
question a roll there ever be another
season of community never thanks for
watching click the we're dry conscious
subscribe to our YouTube channel plus
check out all this cool stuff we know
you love to
[Music]